[Musique]
cyrille melchior président du
département et valère sitel après saad
directeur de l'insertion présenter le
tage tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes
ce jeudi 20 septembre dans l'hémicycle
du palais de la source
c'est un dispositif qui permet à celles
et ceux qui veulent créer leur propre
entreprise de les accompagner dans le
montage de leur dossier mais aussi dans
le suivi et la pérennisation de leurs
entreprises et nous sommes fiers parce
que près de 750 personnes ont été
accompagnées par le département dans la
création de l'entreprise 750 jeunes et
c'est là est une belle réussite et nous
voulons poursuivre dans cette voie un
temps d'échangés entre les jeunes
porteurs de projets les différents
partenaires techniques du réseau point
chance c'est une rencontre d'information
qu'on met en place pour des jeunes de 18
à 30 ans qui ont un projet de création
de petites entreprises et qui sont à la
recherche d'informations pour les
accompagner dans une mise en place de
façon la plus correcte possible avec un
accompagnement de tous les partenaires
les chambres consulaires et tous les
autres
dispositif le réseau point chance tous
ceux qui peuvent les accompagner à
concrétiser leur projet dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
les jeunes ont également pu entendre les
témoignages de bénéficiaires qui ont
accepté de partager leur parcours de vie
le cheminement de leurs projets alors le
tage m'apporter une aide financière pour
pouvoir acheter le matériel de la
société crossfit un mari
c'est une aide qu on ne rembourse pas
déjà donc c'est une subvention et ben
c'est tout simplement un cadeau du
département de la réunion de nous aider
à créer notre entreprise
bah faut pas hésiter à vouloir en
bénéficier à faire les démarches pour
pouvoir en bénéficier
cette année les élus du conseil
départemental ont souhaité ajouter deux
nouveautés à ce dispositif du bas-rhin
suppose création qui de leurs 2800 euros
sur vingt quatre heures de conseil avec
des consultants agréés par le
département à l'accompagnement suppose
création parce qu'il s'agit pour les
élus de pouvoir pérenniser les activités
concernées les accompagner tout au long
de leur développement
et bien entendu vous créer des emplois
pour ces jeunes entreprises la deuxième
également une vente et des élus du
conseil parental c'est de faciliter les
démarches administratives des portes au
projet et donc on est dans l'ère du sur
la paix la dématérialisation des
dossiers de demande de subvention est
véritablement les services départements
mis en oeuvre cette orientation voulue
par nos élus pour que le porte au projet
soit facilité à chaque étape de son
projet et qu'ils soient informés
je dirais de manière instantanée des
pièces qu'il faut transmettre et de
l'état d'avancement de son projet le
tremplin pour l'activité des gènes un
véritable outil d'accompagnement et de
réussite tourné vers l'avenir de nos
jeunes
[Musique]